you want to do another song sure all
right good because atlantis morrison is
very
very exciting for me are you sick of
doing those songs or you still like it
i still love it different versions too
with different band mates
yeah we've been playing different
versions of it or less these dudes are
good these two guys it's
it looks like it's fun i you know i wish
i could do that
yeah well guess what you can't oh shut
up we've seen your karaoke in mind
all right we'll quiet down
[Music]
an old man
turned 98 he won the lottery
and died the next day it's a
black fly in your
chardonnay it's a death row
pardon two minutes to
eat and isn't it ironic
don't you think it's like
[Music]
that you just didn't
mr played safe was afraid to fly
he packed his suit
and kissed his kids goodbye he waited
his lower down life
to take that flight as a plane crashed
down
he thought well isn't this nice
and isn't it ironic don't you
think it's
you just didn't take
[Music]
when you think everything's okay
everything's going right
yeah well life is a funny way of helping
you out when you think
everything's gone wrong and everything
blows up
in your face
a traffic jam when you're already late
i know smoking sign
on your cigarette break
it's like ten 000 spoons but all you
need is a knife
it's meeting the man of my dreams and
meeting his beautiful
husband and isn't it ironic
don't you think a little too
ironic and yeah i really do
think it's like a
[Music]
that you just didn't take
fears
[Music]
i
wow you move me